let's explore what it means to subtract
numbers so let's say that I want to
figure out what for what four minus
three is four minus three so one way to
think about this is you start with four
objects and so let me just draw four
objects so there were I have 1 2 3 & 4
and when I so this is the 4 objects
right over here
and when I say minus 3 or if I'm going
to subtract 3 from the four one way to
think about it is I'm going to take
three of these four objects away so
let's do that so I'm going to take away
1 I'm going to take away 2 and I'm going
to take away 3 notice I take oh I took
away one two three objects so how many
do I have left over well if I start with
four and I take away three I subtract
three four minus three I am left with I
am left with one object right over here
so four minus three is equal to is equal
to one fascinating let's do another one
of these let's figure out what 5 what 5
what 5 minus 2 is let's write it this
way let's say we want to figure out
something some question mark some
question I actually let me just clear
this out so I'll just do it right over
here actually so let's say we have some
question mark so there's some unknown
number right over here so I'll just put
a question mark over here and we say
that unknown number is equal to is equal
to 5 5 minus 2 minus 2 minus 2 so what
is this going to be well let's visualize
this me
I have five things and I'm going to take
away two of them and this is going to be
what I have left over after I start with
five and take away two so I have one two
three four five things and now I am
going to take away two of them so I'm
going to take away one and two so I took
away one two objects so how many do I
have left over well I have left over
these these let me just in a different
color I have left over these purple
things right over here so how many is
that how many do I have left over well I
have left over one two three of my
original five so something is equal to
five minus two that something is three
three is equal to five minus two so let
me just replace this with a three so we
see that three let me do the three in
the same color as this green so we see
that three three is equal to five minus
two or we could say that five minus two
is equal to three
either way